es en este parque de kiev que el
disidente bielorruso vitali sisov fue
hallado muerto colgado de una rama sin
embargo la tesis de suicidio no es la
única línea de investigación con la
policía valorando un ahorcamiento por
asesinato
las grabaciones de las cámaras están en
el centro de la pesquisa y buscamos
cualquier eventual testigos estamos
verificando todas las pistas ya sea por
suicidio u homicidio disfrazado de
suicidio de 26 años y soft se marchó de
belarús en 2020 tras ser uno de los
manifestantes más fervientes contra el
presidente alexander lukashenko fue
justo en ucrania donde halló refugio y
decidió crear una ong de respaldo para
otros vuelos rusos además de alta voz
contra el gobierno si
hoy estamos en la embajada de austria
para pedir al gobierno austriaco que
cese de cooperar con el régimen de
lukashenko
según su entorno el activista se sentía
amenazado desde hace varios meses y
llegó a notificarlo a las autoridades
ucranianas el lunes su pareja advirtió
de su desaparición al salir a correr
mientras que el amigo que identificó su
cuerpo advirtió que si yo tenía la nariz
rota
repito que se trata de una ejecución con
el fin de intimidar a todas las personas
activas en ucrania
palabras que resuenan también en la
opositora zlatan ática nos calla que se
encuentra en exilio en lituania
al descender entiendo que puedo
desaparecer en cualquier momento lo
entiendo pero creo hacer lo correcto y
no puedo pararme incluso si algún día
desapareciera el movimiento continuaría
sin mí las autoridades de ming nos han
pronunciado todavía sobre la muerte de
vital y giselle